he is none other than Matt Ryan here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you Matt
Ryan I am doing great rich how are you I
am doing I am doing uh better for
talking to you I'll be very very honest
Matt that's very nice of you so again
where where'd this all come from for a
team that had one win and two straight
double use Matt where do you how do you
ascribe this yeah it's it's it's a
head-scratcher for us you know we felt
like the first half of the season just
you know wasn't who we are and you know
we just weren't very consistent and and
you know last two weeks I think we
played complimentary football we've done
a good job in all three phases of just
going out playing the way that we're
capable of not doing anything crazy but
just but just playing good football and
so you know where our backs are against
the wall for sure but it is nice to see
us playing the way we were capable of
playing and in terms of hearing about
your coach being on the hot seat and how
Arthur Blank was quoted almost after
every game did any of that play into you
coming and your team coming together
more cohesively Matt Ryan well you know
we all loved and there's no question
about that and I think you know he's
he's he's a great coach I mean he's
awesome in the locker room guys really
you know enjoy playing for him and so as
players you take you know personal
responsibility for that you want to win
games you want to keep keep guys here
and it's been good you know the last
couple of weeks to the locker room and
kind of rally in and in you know
heightened in our focus and all those
things have been really good so we just
need to keep that rolling did the bye
week helped I think it did you know I
think it gives everybody a chance to
kind of take a deep breath get away from
it for a second you know refocus and and
reenergize and gave our staff an
opportunity to kind of do a self Scout
and take a look at at what we needed to
emphasize in the second half of the
season I think we've we've certainly
been better
you know since since that week off and
we need to just you know keep this
momentum rolling and in terms of the
self Scout what did you find did you
find anything I mean at this late
obviously stage of your career
having been in it for as long as you
have and any self scouting on your part
Matt well I think you know for sure you
know when we trade it Muhammad which was
you know always tough as players
he's great teammate and he's doing a
great job in New England now but when we
trade it Muhammad for me the self scale
portion of it was okay you know how do
we feature some of these guys that we
have to utilize now and that was kind of
the biggest thing in that week off was
saying all right you know what's a guy
like Russell gage look like for us in
the offense now how do we increase
Calvin Ridley's production and use him
in different ways and that was kind of
my focus you know during that time was
was was defined ways that we could plug
those guys in and and be more productive
with them Matt Ryan Atlanta Falcons
quarterback after an icy start now
heating up on the Rich Eisen show here
after two straight double use what does
it mean to you to be top 10 now on the
all-time passing yards like you passed
Warren Moon Matt that's a serious name
that you passed on that list yeah I mean
it's I've gotten to know Warren
throughout my career and seeing him a
number of different times and was a huge
fan of his growing up and you know I'm
not sure anybody threw a prettier ball
and then him so you know to kind of be
on that list and in you know hopefully
to continue to work my way up is it's
you know it's pretty cool and it's one
of those things you think back to like
you know when I was 10 years old if you
would have told me that you know what
would I have thought at that time and
and you know I would have I would have
been blown away and now having done it
as long as I've done it in the league
it's it's been a lot of fun but
hopefully there's there's a lot more to
come
yeah I mean in terms of the more to come
on I know again your your team guide do
you know the next name on the list for
you Matt well yes about it yesterday I
dunno the next name on the list and
that's a really good name as well that's
John Elway I mean
I mean that I mean that's amazing it
really it really is a I mean that's a
big name to that you've got right there
in front of you yes well I've got a
little ways to go and hopefully a lot
more wins between now and then whenever
that may be and if it happens but you
know John Hill a he's the man that's for
sure and you know be be pretty special
to keep climbin Matt Ryan Falcons
quarterback hit me here on the Rich
Eisen show just apropos of outside there
was as you know the Kaepernick workout
at flowery branch just was there any way
any sort of circumstance behind the
scenes that uh if you will just
logistically messed with the schedule in
a way for the Falcons last week for you
to be prepared for your game etc and so
on just it didn't it didn't affect you
know any any of the the players or you
know in terms of our scheduling or
practice times or anything like that or
affect our meetings I know there was a
lot going on around our building for
sure and you know people outside of the
gates all those kind of things there was
just you know and a lot of extra
busyness that he don't typically see on
the day-to-day but as far as players
nothing really you know changed for us
yeah yeah I mean cuz I just remember
when I shot an NFL Network commercial
years ago on the Falcons facility I mean
this is when I had hair and this is way
back when you might even been in in in a
high school even matter earlier on in
Boston College we had Torry Holt of the
Rams come in and be part of that
commercial and he had to stay in a
trailer way off the grounds because the
Falcons wanted no part of a player for
an opposing team in and I could only
imagine with 31 potentially other teams
coming to a facility that had to create
some sort of logistical setup there was
there was definitely more security and
more people around that you don't
typically see on the day-to-day so that
part of it was was a little bit unique
okay so now I find that commercial by
the way by the way
you know what it was amazing it was this
is what the time it was it was head
coach Dan Reeves in quarterback Michael
Vick
in the Atlanta facility and yeah the the
it was the dear mr. fantasy was the song
and it said being rich doesn't suck that
was the conversation I like you know way
way back in the day because as you know
it's it is all about branding Matt you
know and it's about what people call you
and and how you go about your business
you know I'm saying have you picked up a
theme in the way that I've I've reset
your name throughout this entire
conversation I see win the other day
nicely done I'm just trying to give you
what you want Matt you know do you want
to play play the drop that Matt Ryan
provided us in the last conversation
here that we use every single time I
kind of feel like what a receiver must
feel like when they go back to the
huddle telling Matt I'm open that's what
it sounds like you know yeah is that
what you tell Julio like you got to move
on Zoe tell him when he comes back to
you all the time no man I'm a little bit
more delicate oh man
okay so now I mean are you guys they can
playoff run like actually verbalizing
this sort of thing Matt and this I know
it's a one day at a time one game at a
time world but is this the sort of
conversation that maybe you're having
after two straight WT we've got a ways
to go and we gotta have a lot of things
happen for sure so that's not you know
necessarily the the the storyline for us
yet but I've been around long enough to
know that crazy stuff happens in this
league and if you just keep winning
games and keep you know playing good
football anything had happened and so
you know until we're out of it we're
gonna keep calling and scratching and
you know trying to play the kind of
football that we're capable of playing I
mean you're in the stretch of five
games against division opponents you've
won your first - you've got Tampa coming
in and I know for a fact that you've had
a Thanksgiving game in Atlanta before
because I was part of the NFL Network
crew that hosted it and Arthur blank
opened up his office and I say that in
quotes it's not like a cubicle with like
a laptop on it it was this beautiful
spot that all of the NFL Network folks
came to are you what what are your
Thanksgiving plans how do you work that
you know you got kids you got family I'm
sure coming in what what is that over
the steering wheel for a couple years
from now Matt it uh you know it starts
with trying to get a W that that night
and then we just delay it a day you know
we've got the weekend after we pray you
know pretend it's it something's giving
on Friday okay I have a little meal and
enjoy it and you know that's that's
pretty much it but you know it's just a
delayed gratification of an eating fest
I guess hold it off for one more day so
what you're saying is you put the meal
on ice is that what you're saying
exactly you just put it all on ice
because that's what you do because
that's what you got running through your
veins right here you nailed it perfect
thanks for the call Matt I always
appreciate our chats you know that rich
you are the best stop that
by the way they cut out the fact that
you said I love you but you got to move
on which is an outrage Matt I know I do
love you man you're the best
thank you Matt Ryan I love you but you
gotta move on thanks to the call Matt
appreciate it all right you got it you
got that's Matt Ryan for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app